Millennials don't like to be nanny they
opt for personal choice over government
regulation across a number of products
and activities that many governments
have already banned or have sought to
ban for instance 57% favor legalizing
marijuana 58% favor legalizing online
gambling in addition six and ten say
that people should be allowed to use
e-cigarettes in public places they also
think people should be allowed to buy
traditional incandescent light bulbs and
that people should be allowed to eat
trans fats and even though New York City
tried to ban it nearly 3/4 of
Millennials say that people should be
allowed to sell large sugary drinks in
restaurants and theaters two-thirds of
Millennials say government ought to
allow same-sex couples to get married
not only that a majority of Republican
Millennials also say that government
should allow same-sex marriage this is
actually part of a broader socially
liberal shift we're finding among young
Republicans in fact four in ten
self-identify as being socially liberal
Millennials also think it's time for us
to lower the drinking age and this is
not just being driven by college
students in fact Millennials over 21
also think that we should lower the
drinking age a majority 54% think that
the laws that we have in place simply
are ineffective and 1/4 go so far as to
say that these laws are actually causing
more problems than they solve
Millennials have grown up in a world a
fast-paced technological change and
they've become accustomed to having lots
of choices and being able to personalize
things and this has led them to value
individual autonomy we see that these
experiences have impacted their
political attitudes